thank you
you
right okay good evening and welcome
everyone to virtual meeting of planning
committee a my name is Danny Kendall
I'll be chairing this evening's meeting
in accordance with the rules and
procedures has been set out before we
move on if I could just run through very
quickly a bit of housekeeping to make
sure that we're all up to speed on that
also
apologies what I just click to the chat
so I can see what's going on there right
so housekeeping and you'll be you will
have been provided with the council's
etiquette the virtual meetings in
advance of this that just to reiterate a
few key points please do make sure your
device is fully charged or is charging
so it doesn't just switch off at some
point during the meeting please mute
very importantly please mute microphones
when you're not speaking what invites to
address the committee please insure your
microphone is switched on when you have
finished addressing the committee please
- microphone immediately
please ensure that you have switched off
any other devices which I will also make
sure of now so make sure all mobile
phones are on silent do interrupt if any
member of the committee encounters IT
problems cause you need to drop out of
the meeting at any point please make
your best efforts to rejoin the meeting
as quickly as possible
should the member will not be able to
rejoin you will be deemed to have left
the meeting at that point and the
committee will proceed as normal as long
as it remains court committee members we
need to just very quickly run through do
a quick roll call of you to make sure
that you're all here and that you're all
able to see and hear the proceedings
that I asked Olivia Quinn from
democratic services just a very quick
roll call for me please start with you
comes to Kendall I confirm that I can
hear it and see proceedings councillor
Richards don't stir Richards I can
confirm I can see and hear all
proceedings
councillor Adam
I can hear all the leading councillor
Dixon councillor Dixon present can see
and hear I have to say that councillor
Adam came through on letting very poor
vocal and we're trying to about during
the meeting councillor Eden counselor ed
and I can see in here or proceedings
councillor Jennings can start earning as
I concerned here or proceedings and cats
repair a good evening everybody
councillor Perry I can see and hear
everything
Thank You Olivia we've gone through this
before of course but if a counselor does
wish to speak on an item please could
you indicate this through the chat
function on the right hand side of the
screen if you just say something
otherwise it can I speak please and
hopefully I'll notice that very quickly
I'll bring you in at the right moment
right officers could ask you to
introduce yourselves as well Olivia
could we start with you please Olivia
Quinn democratic services thank you
Mina Mina Mack legal services Thank You
Tracy
Thank You Germany so I'm Tracy Humphries
and I'm your planning manager for
tonight's meeting Thank You Tracy and
then we have our offices so we harun
aaron weather steering officer thank you
allas allas cost nap planning officer
thank you and tony tony Horton's Senior
Planner thank you think we've got
everyone which is fantastic so just to
remind people obviously this meeting is
being webcast and should you want to
live it back again the next day that you
can please be aware of course that it's
being broadcast in the images and sound
recordings may be used for training
purposes at a future date
public speakers a quick note to you guys
as well you'll be given obviously
set amount of time in the different for
each peak that each person I'll go over
that at the right moment and you'll also
be given a 30-second warning before the
end of your speaking allocation could I
ask you though to make sure that you
don't immediately leave the meeting when
you finish speaking please stay on the
line just in case there any questions
from the committee
moving to voting when we do come to vote
on any of the applications tonight if I
can remind members of the committee that
they should respond with your name and
then are cleared for against or
abstaining all right those are the
pieces of housekeeping we've got for the
virtual meeting we move to agenda item 1
apologies for absence charlie but no
apologies Thank You Olivia item agenda
two disclosure of interest I'll kick
this one off if that's okay I received a
number of emails regarding regarding the
first application tonight which cited
for application reference 19 side zero
to nine to three slash ful and I will
declare that on behalf the entire
committee exactly everybody was copied
in on that so that's that disclosure
interests are there any other disclosure
of interests please
Dixon I could say not a doctor pecuniary
interest but I am supporting my
residents on the third item tonight the
application for the reinstatement of PD
rights on violence so Carol Dixon I
understand that you'll step down from
the Commission for that before I
register speak as the war member that is
correct thank you Thank You chairman
Oh chair medius sorry about that
apologies Rodgers can I confirm that we
all content within minutes of the
meeting held on the 17th of June I'll
accept a nodding of heads from the
committee and if that's okay if not
speak up now that's wonderful I will
sign those in due course in which case
we can move to our first application of
the evening this item for Karen on page
five of your agendas this is application
reference 19 / 0 - 9 - 3 / ful that is
for Churchland care about site
Churchill's business park often Road
harboring this the description is for
the change of use of land to a caravan
and Counting site for 51 pitches to
touring units and also involves a
revised layout retention of a static
caravan for residential occupation
provision of lighting drainage
landscaping and a public foot way
presenting officer for this applications
air and weather stone Erin over to you
please my confirm that everyone can see
the presentation on the screen perfect
the application sight lines for
Northeast of Harvey village as
identified by the black dot on this plan
just here
Harvey is identified as a category one
local service village within the council
- adopted core strategy - site lies
outside of the settlement boundary
identified within the adopted
neighborhood plan in the countryside the
site lies directly north of the railway
line and east of public bite of weary SM
24 I'm sorry I can't
yeah the presentation is not rolling
through if you could just read trying to
reshare your string what I'll do is I'll
reshare it sorry about that and see if
it works the second time I can't see the
presentation now yes George just flip
forward a slide or two to make sure it's
working yeah thank you thank you so the
application site lies to the northeast
of Harbor Village as identified by the
black dot on the plan just here
harpy's identified as a category one
local service village within the
council's adopted core strategy the site
lies outside of the settlement boundary
identified within the adopted
neighborhood plan in the countryside the
site lies directly north of the railway
line and east of public right-of-way DSM
24 this slide identifies the application
site outlined in red just here beside
comprises of a parcel of agricultural
land located to the north of Churchill
ins Business Park just here access to
the site is shared with other businesses
and connects to the Upton Road to the
west just here
public right-of-way SM 24 is visible to
the west of the site as identified by
the green dashed line on the plan just
shown here on the plan the railway line
in the edge of Harvey settlement are
visible to the south of the site but the
railway line here the Harvey settlement
just here
planning permission is sought the
material change of use of the land for
camping and caravan site 451 pitches
the touring units including touring
caravans motorhomes trailer tents and
tents the development also includes a
retention of a mobile home for
residential occupation and associated
works including lighting drainage
landscaping and a new public foot wave
which will connect the site to harpie
village along the Afghan Road in this
section here the works apart
retrospective interface a mobile home is
currently sited on the land and the site
is being used as a touring caravan site
with an informal layout this slide shows
an aerial image of the area the site is
visible to the north of the existing
built buildings just here the settlement
of Harbury and there while we're lino
visible to the south you see Hari here
on the railway line just here to the
south since this image was taken
additional works have been carried out
to the west and east of the site to the
west a new access has been restored
approximate here a new hard standing is
in this location here and engineering
works have been carried out to the east
of the site at a time of the cyclist at
last Friday works were also being
carried out to the railway embankment to
the south in this area approximately
here this slide shows a proposed side
layout the development seeks to retain
the existing particular access from
church and this Business Park an
existing field access points to the
north here and south east of the site
the main access with the caravans coming
in here gravel and access road is
proposed to serve the 26 hard standing
pictures to the south of the site this
area here to the north of the site 25
grass pitches are proposed with
reinforced Greta tracks here here and
here on the plan existing mobile home on
the site proposed to be retained in its
current location to the south east of
the site the mobile home just here
service points and facilities proposed
for cursed ethnic customers within the
site include shower and toilet
facilities water power and thin storage
new trees and hedgerow plantings
proposed as part of the development and
the hedge along the northern boundary of
the site is proposed to be restocked
among its full length where the sighted
joins a country's
this hedgerow here this SlideShare to
propose Footwear which will connect the
development to Harbury village just on
this side here proposed foot winglet
measure approximately 120 meters in
length and would vary in width between
1.2 and 1.5 meters the foot way seeks to
introduce a new drop cab which will
connect to the existing that way which
leads into harvey village we've got a
connection point just here and here
proposal also seeks to replace existing
bus stop the photograph to the right of
the slide show the eastern edge of the
upturn road where the footwear is
proposed to be installed so just here as
here on the photographs this slide shows
a photograph taken from a road to the
north looking back towards the
application site the approximate
location of the site is indicated by the
red arrow approximately here this slide
shows a photograph taken from the off
turn road looking towards a site again
the width the red arrow indicates the
approximate location of the site this
slide shows the vehicle access to the
site from the often Road moving from the
left image over here the site access
travels from the often rode catholic
lifting businesses which is shown in
photograph to here down a track in
photograph three then across the parcel
of land where the caravans are located
just at the rear a photograph for just
here this photograph was taken looking
eastwards across the site from the
entrance of the touring caravan area
just looking across the site this
photograph was taken looking a Southwest
and direction from within the site the
mobile home is visible to the right of
the image just here and to the rear you
can see the buildings associated with
church nuns Business Park this
photograph has taken from the edge of
the site looking in the southwestern
direction the slide shows a photograph
which was taken looking in a western
direction across the site these distant
planting along the northern boundary is
visible to the right of the image just
here the slide shows a photograph which
was taken looking a southeast
directional cross the site this
photograph has taken credit to the field
access to the north of the site looking
back across the applications right there
are a number of updates for this
application which have been circulated
on the update sheet it is recommended
that Planning Commission be refused for
the reasons set out in the officer
report thank you Thank You Erin
brilliant stuff um before we get to our
first speaker just a quick word on that
Update sheet just so everybody commends
the public as well know it was quite a
long updated sheet it was circulated
earlier on today and all members of the
Planning Committee have been given about
15-20 minutes to read and digest that
before the meeting started just so
they're always clear on that point as
well right in that case we go to our
first speaker this is calculus counselor
Samantha Allen from Harbury Parish
Council counselor Allen are you there
you
hello hello counselor Allen can you hear
me I can hear you perfectly and I'm
getting nods from the rest of the
committee that's fantastic thank you for
joining us tonight
you've got three minutes to address the
committee at the end of that three
minutes would you please stay on the
line interesting case there any
questions from the committee and I will
give you a 30-second warning before the
ends of your time if that's okay well
whenever you're ready please begin
yes so I'm from Harbury Parish Council
we supported this application especially
because of the integration of the new
public footpath that they were proposing
to install which was a significant
change from the previous application the
benefit would be for that for the
trading estate and the caravan park
that's already located here the officers
report refers to see non-compliance with
policies hero1 and hero2 our
neighborhood development plan and we
consider that this has been
misinterpreted and these policies have
been written for provision of permanent
residential dwellings and as such was
considered his application for touring
units not to be impacted by these
policies in regard to policy af10 from
the local plan we believe there is a
demonstrable need shown as this is a
part partially retrospective application
there are ongoing works at Harper
touching by Network Rail which this site
is adjacent to in this proof has
provided increased economic benefits
over many years to hardly village we
consider this aligns with paragraph 83
and 84 of the NEPA MPPs which seek to
support a prosperous rural rural economy
we also considered the local plan policy
CS 24 is fully justified there just
under 1 hectare site is directly
associated with the long term business
use sites network rail since
2016 the case officer's report indicates
that the site should conform to a major
existing tourist or recreation facility
in addition to this however the written
policy clearly indicates that it's not
necessary to comply with all of these
conclusion the report also refer
two CS 15 from the local plan regarding
personal development once more this has
been misinterpreted and taken out of
context as again the policy is written
for permanent residential dwellings and
no weight should be afforded to this
hardly parish council therefore consider
that this application is sufficiently
supported by these policies and we will
reconfirm our support for this
application at this committee meeting
thank you thank you very much councillor
um you have plenty of time left as well
do we have any questions from the
committee before the parish council
please if you'd like to indicate in the
chat please just give that two seconds
okay okay thank you please Thank You
councillor Richard speaking and I thank
you very much for your presentation
there I'm you mentioned your qualities
actually one actually four and that
they've been misinterpreted I wonder if
you can expand a little bit on that for
me and also let me know if there's
anything within your NDP that policy
wise that doesn't support this
application any specific policy the only
anything in our NDP that it's supposed
to be open to interpretation is where
we've donated our built-up area boundary
but because this is a commercial site
not in residential site it shouldn't
really apply because you know the
development policies have been written
for residential development H I want
them ho4 have been written for for
housing for permanent housing but this
is this is recurring and we considered
it economically it's a benefit to our
village even in the position that it is
outside the area boundary versus that's
fine thank you very much right if I'm
not picking up any further questions
from the committee
so in which case accounts for Alan thank
you very much for your time tonight
okay thank you thank you okay we can go
to our next speaker I hope we've got
Patrick Atherton please agent for the
applicant Strath attorney you there
mr. Atherton
he's on jackin you need to press star
six to unmute
star six to unmute can you hear me yes
mr. Atherton thank you hello thank you
for waiting
good something yes abused abused came
before like this and I'm finding that
the what I can hear on my telephone is
not in sync with what I can see and what
I can see is several seconds probably a
minute behind what I'm hearing on my
telephone so I can't follow exactly what
is being said because it's very
confusing I think given the
circumstances with the mercy of
Technology internet connections at the
moment it will take point on board and
we'll continue to work with our IT
specialist to mate for example at the
moment you're looking straight at me but
you're not talking well so where I can't
hear everything you're saying
so I think the meeting can proceed if
you were happy to continue it's
obviously okay from your point of view
but not for mine this because that what
I'm hearing on the phone isn't in sync
with what is happening actually in the
committee which is very confusing I'm
sorry to hear that mr. Allen to be
honest with you at this point we're at
an impasse if you don't want to speak
you don't have to it's up to you I think
I do want to speak but I'm just letting
you know that it's not satisfactory from
my point of view and I know we'll
continue to work with future meetings
leave it with us for now I presume you
heard the the rules for the other
speaker you have three minutes if you
please don't leave the line after the
three minutes dessert we may have some
questions for you and I'll give you a
warning at the last 30 seconds mr. -
over to you
the recommendation to refuse relies on
the following the proposal is not
small-scale tourism development in
policy pas 10s it proposes large-scale
development for 80-plus units in the
table of park k3 camping in Caravan
sites policy CS 24 requires large-scale
overnight accommodation development to
be located in stratford-on-avon or a
main rural center the pro proposal will
cause harm defined as a principle my
rebuttal is obviously IES 10 s is a
presumption of favour of small-scale
tourism and visitor accommodation
developed in the countryside but not to
the exclusion of anything else
however tourism and leisure related
schemes will also be assessed against
the provisions of policy CS 24 part K 3
applies to policy CS 24 part K 3 table
defines proposal 451 touring units as
medium scale large scale applies to 80
plus units the table is unlawful because
it does not comply with do circular 2083
model standards for touring caravans
planning permission was granted in 2017
for 20 static cations at Harvey fields
farm increasing 58 units to 78 that is a
medium scale development policy CS 24
states large scale schemes for visitor
attractions or overnight accommodation
should wherever possible be located
within the urban areas of
stratford-upon-avon or a main rural
center it is not possible to locate the
caravan site in these urban areas policy
CS 24 provides an exception for large
scale proposals for new tourism
development to be located in the
countryside subject to seven criteria
with which the proposal complies the
harm alleged is the benefits of the
scheme are not considered to outweigh
the harm identified with the principle
of locating large scale visitor
accommodation open countryside in close
proximity to a local service village
rather than Stratford on a min town or a
main rural center the proposal is not a
large-scale the report identifies many
benefits but does not identify any harm
that would be caused to the countryside
planning principle is not evidence of
harm even if the proposal was
large-scale it would be considered
the relevant policy to which I just
referred policy cs20 for farm
diversification the Carolina kamek site
is farm diversification colluding to the
farm business and agricultural use the
land would contribute 350 pound per
annum compared with 15,000 231 last year
thank you 30 seconds since his father's
death Adam is ruining the farming
business on the Carry website
Adam is an essential agricultural worker
the only accommodation available to in
and his family is their mobile home his
mother still lives in the farm house the
land can continue to be used with any
student rights these are part for Class
B 28 days camping and part 5 Class A use
as a caravan site paragraph 9 allows
land to be used to provide accommodation
for persons employed in building and
engineering operations being undertaken
on the stock in there I think we've got
a very good idea what your what your
points were and the case you're making
could I ask the members of the committee
do they have any questions they would
like to ask mr. hatten the age of the
applicant if you could indicate in the
chat please I'm not seeing anything come
up here oh yes council Richards
Thank You chairman council Richards here
and thank you to the agent there for his
little speech I just wanted to get
clarity on your on what you've said
specifically around policy CS 24 it
sounds like you were saying that you
don't thinks CS 24 has been interpreted
correctly is that right or are you
saying it hasn't been considered at all
no it's not been interpreted correctly
the policy allows exceptions subject to
compliance for seven criteria this
application complies with those some
criteria
in addition to that I'm saying that the
development isn't large-scale it's a
medium scale according to the numbers of
pitches there's actually no provision in
the local plan that relates them medium
scale whatsoever
there's just small-scale and large-scale
the no consideration has been given in
that point okay understood I think that
I think it's a it's a question over
interpretation rather than thing else I
just want that clarity thank you so much
thank you
if there are no other questions for our
speaker I think around mr. Aston thank
you very much for your time this evening
it's appreciated
in which case we move to our next
speaker care ward member I should say
councillor Harris yes I see you there
evening everyone can you hear me it's
counselor Harris perfect Thank You
counselor you know the routine you
haven't you have five minutes to speak
and obviously stand on in the meeting at
the end of that time so we can ask the
questions
yes Harris over to you Thank You chair
I think the Parish Council I'm rather
tonneau cover the points of Sinclair
regarding policy I will also ask the
young committee just to bear in mind the
current climate worrying around business
and jobs and creating jobs I think it's
been a difficult three or four months
and businesses hit hard and this would
help the local economy and the area
substantially I would like to say I
spoke to a mr. Leon Richardson who's
been a site manager with Murphy's for
quite some years he spent time about six
years in Harvey managing the emergency
embankment and engineering works and
other ongoing works and obviously we've
got HS to in the area as well and he's
telling me that he's had many dealings
with the four more family due to the
source location of affordable
accommodation for the many employees
during the major railway projects it was
affordable accommodation which is not
usually available elsewhere in the area
especially around Harvey and its local
area may at least have a lot of work
ongoing and new contracts commencing in
the future they do need accommodation as
I would have thought HS to do and
they'll need this going forward for
quite a few years I understand probably
10 to 15 due to the seriousness of
making sure the trains could travel as
well as normal with no danger to life
the works have been undertaken quickly
they would not have completed these
works and they required timescale if he
hadn't a common had the accommodation at
Churchill's farm caravan site which is
minimized traveling time which obviously
supports our own plan with reducing
emissions and saving the planet and the
location
society saying ideal for them Murphy's
employees but it's also environmentally
sustainable the apparently speaks for
himself only the Murphy's employees that
the caravan site hadn't existed we would
have would not been able to carry out
the work as efficiently and safely as
they have as a family business Murphy's
have a real good relationship with local
residents in the village and have
carried out numerous works for the
community their employees support local
businesses and the local economy church
loons Caravan farm and its site is
essential for all including other
contractors who are involved in the
works around the area the current
application proposal to upgrade the
layout of the facilities and services
would be very welcome and strongly
supported by the local businesses from
this gentleman's knowledge people from
the village have been injured by
vehicles when walking on Ogden road
between Harvey and the public footpath
the Churchland Business Park the absence
of the football and Ogden road is a
major risk especially at nighttime so
provision of a new Footwear link with
the public foot pack is a must this is
what we're really pushing for and he
assures me that he's wore of that group
many time so aside from the policy
aspect of it I will just put the
committee just think at the moment with
the business interests and supporting of
the local community thank you everyone
Thank You Chancellor Harris excellent to
have any questions for the ward member
from the committee Chancellor Perry
Thank You chairman and good evening
counselor Harris obviously you've
highlighted there's been a lot of
support by by the locals and the parish
council etc there is no in the committee
report there is nothing reflecting to
people objecting and I just wonder
whether you know you're you're aware of
any other you know people objecting who
perhaps haven't haven't written through
or is it you know you're indicating
there is overwhelming support for this
from the village I just would be
interested to have your views on that
good evening council Perry nice to hear
from you and see you and know I've had
no other objections it's overwhelmingly
support on so many different levels for
this
thank you thank you
I've not got any further questions in
the chat amount so if that's the case
counselor Harris thank you very much for
your time this evening okay sorry I
meant to say Thank You chair but I
didn't a mute it's fine thank you
lovely stuff right okay let's go two
points of clarification for
clarification from the committee us
again do you have any questions from the
committee for the officers councillor
Jennings councillor Jennings here just
wanted a bit more clarification on this
large scale or small scale and then
there seems to be a sort of medium scale
and it seems to be I don't understand
I'd like to be informed to clarify to
please
thank you we have part K of the
council's adopted SPD which officers are
affording full weight and that has a
table on page three which gives a number
of factors you can take into account
when considering if a development small
scale medium scale or large scale so
based on the circumstances of this
particular case and officers consider
there is a large scale site and we'd
assess it on that basis
so does that cover the caravans or is
that directed for housing so this
relates to holiday let's and caravan
parks park any of the SPD and we're
looking at the number of units whether
or not it's seasonal use what sort of
facilities are provided and we've
assessed it as part it's to assist
officers in their planning judgment so
we've assessed it based on the
information specific to this case and
we've use this as a guide to look at
particular factors which may indicate if
it's small medium or large scale there's
no specific number numbers are a
consideration so the number of caravans
but we'd also be looking at the site the
facilities how long it's opened forth
its seasonal or all year round you so
those are key considerations as well
that we take into account when we're
assessing any developments thank you
please Thank You chairman I can sort two
speaking I was going on system the
question that Chancellor Jennings over
the interpretation of CS 24 but you've
answered that nicely for me there the
other question I had was about the
interpretation of the Neighborhood
Development Plan we've heard from the
parish council and they believe that
policies h o1 h a4 have been interpreted
incorrectly it does I don't have the
benefit of the full neighborhood plan in
front of me obviously I've got your
report which does specifically say that
has in development within the village is
there anything else within the
neighborhood development plan to your
mind that would otherwise support this
type of development or a commercial
venture in that location and is there
any other way that could we want would
otherwise to interpret the two policies
that have been referred to so with
regard to the name of the development
plan we have assessed it as officers as
part of our assessment and the key
policies that we've looked at our h1 in
h4 whether looking outside of the
settlement boundaries which is
identified by the neighborhood
development plan so we've looked at this
development we've looking at it as a
change of use of land for a caravan site
for 12 months of the year where
occupation by people going on holiday
and also contractors working in the area
so we've considered it on that day
there were no other policies having
looked through the NDP to my mind that
would be applicable to this type of
development and so we have been assessed
against of course strategy policy CS 24
and a s 10 assert the key principle
policies for this development fantastic
thank you Thank You councillor Perry
Thank You chairman I'm socially going to
ask something very very similar which
has been responded to by Aaron and and
if I can just go back to the SPD now
obviously it was adopted in July 2019
but I am assuming that policy would have
been written quite some time before
Julie it would have been written earlier
in the year in view of all the
consultation and the time it takes to
become adopted would that be correct
Aaron so that's when it was adopted yes
so it's July last year that the SPD was
adopted the policies were already in the
core strategy this was just to provide
extra assistance to officers when
carrying out their assessments Thank You
councillor Dixon
if you children mute thank you gentlemen
um if funny permission is granted this
evening
obviously the papers before has
indicated an application for 51 pictures
split between two caravans and tents etc
will the conditions and enable a
restriction to of those numbers because
obviously Aaron in her assessment says
that apart from looking at the numbers
she was also looking at the facilities
being provided which to my mind was
suggestive that she was afraid of a
greater number of pitches subsequently
happening because of the facilities
personally I'm looking at this one I
think in it's a medium-sized Karen can
you address that horse in terms of the
numbers and we are able to limit the
number of pictures and the number of
caravans at this point in time it's 51
pitches which could be a combination of
tents touring caravans trailer tents all
motorhomes
and so it could be a variation of any of
those with the one static motorhome that
proposed for permanent residential
accommodation and in the committee of
course it goes into more detail about
the assessment and it's the size of the
site was also a consideration the number
of pitches the occupation the
engineering works and to accommodate the
proposed you so those are the key and
factors in this case of officers to
think of accounts
okay oh it's canceled Jennings one more
question counselor Jennings it's just a
clarification water
what are they got planning permission
for at the moment at the moment it's
understood that the site is operating
with a certificate exemption for five
caravan site which doesn't need planning
permission and the rest of the works are
retrospective and do not benefit from
the Planning Commission at this moment
in time so we're considering it as a
retrospective action application to
regularize and improve the facilities on
the site thank you
right counselor
apologies chairman I'm Erin the various
pictures that you put up as part of your
presentation showed really quite a quite
a lot you know sort of it looks though
about thirty twenty twenty to thirty
Caravan touring caravans and motorhomes
if you're saying it is can you just
explain why there would be so many
pitched when when we're looking at this
proposal this evening
or are we or is it in total
retrospective so the use of the land is
currently being used and for the siting
of the mobile home which was shown in
the photographs in the presentation and
for the use of the land for touring
caravans with an informal layout and so
it is retrospective in that respect but
the extra works the engineering works
that the new facilities that are
proposed also what we're considering as
part of this application so it's part to
regularize in part two and add in new
facilities for customers
okay and councillor Adam thank you it
was just in relation to the CS 24 things
that the the applicant agent mentioned
in relation to where they were outside
of urban sort of rural centers obviously
this isn't within the Aurora center I
think the nearest one is about three and
a half miles away being Salim but you
mentioned that there are seven points
which I'm looking at suggesting that it
did meet those as a large development
can you just clarify why you consider
that it doesn't meet those seven
criteria set out in our core strategy
yes in terms of CS 24 it talks about
large cow scheme to visitor attractions
or overnight accommodation where
wherever possible should be located
within the urban areas of Stratford or a
main rural center it also goes into
detail to say that large-scale district
history accommodation may be justified
in rural parts of the district where
it's directly associated with its
associated with our ancillary to a major
existing tourist recreation conference
or other form of business and it just
have a number of points but that refers
to that we look at in terms of it will
need teacher as if I take into account a
number of criteria so we look at it as a
whole and but in this case officers
don't consider it's fully justified in
the rural location because if we're
looking at the development in the
countryside and that's where officers
have raised concerns with the principle
of the development on that basis okay
thank you okay any other questions so
move to the debate you want to kick us
off on the debate Chancellor Perry thank
you chairman um we're living in a very
sort of fast-moving changing scenario
here aren't we
and I and obviously when the court call
strategy was developed no one had any
idea that 2020 would turn out to be the
year it does and I think one only has to
look at what the way government
has had to move in such a fast way to
protect businesses and I've been trying
to look at and assess this on the basis
of off the harm its location
certainly the location seems it's
there's there's no concern by residents
in fact it's got the full support of the
parish council
it's got full support from the residents
which is a pretty rare thing for a
caravan site to be honest with you I
don't think I've ever I've been on this
planning committee for about six years
and I've never had a situation where
we've got a caravan site with full
support from the parish council and all
the villagers and and the residents I do
think you know I do think it's a way of
interpretation and I'm inclined to go
against the officers recommendation and
go and to support this because I'm
interpreting cs20 for supporting tourism
and I do believe there is a need because
of obviously the public foot way and
also affordable accommodation as well so
having looked at this heard all the
various arguments and I understand where
the officers are coming from from a pure
policy perspective but we're not
operating in the real world at the
moment and I think we need to be doing
everything we can to support rural
businesses councillor Dixon please
thank you Thank You chairman I agree
with with councillor Perry essentially
when I looked at this one and read the
report
I thought the officer have come to you
know a balance to judgment but I thought
it was a fairly finely balanced to
judgment essentially one of the
paragraphs in the report the development
is considered to introduce a number of
benefits including economic benefits to
the settlement surrounding areas by
supporting the local economy environment
benefits in the form of increased
planting increased choice alternative
modes of transport improved access with
visitors and residents of Harbury
throughout the creation of a new foot
way and they provide choice for a
tourist accommodation within the
district I personally would hate to
think that a facility that is not linked
or close to stratford-upon-avon or the
other main rural centers had to be
linked to a major tourist destination
I'm thinking of cotton court etc would
they really want a caravan site very
close to them I don't see the logic of
trying to connect such developments as
this to local tourist attractions and
therefore I would be in favor of
granting this application thank you John
Thank You counselor chat actually
Richard speaking Thank You chairman I so
I'm going to disagree with the previous
two speakers and I'll try to explain why
if I first start we clearly yes we do
live in a different environment now from
the moment we we were in one course - it
was written but that change shouldn't
render our core strategy and its policy
is redundant they still apply and they
still are our policies and this very
much hinges on the interpretation of
those policies as has been made clear by
both the parish council and the year the
agent and to my mind addressing the the
parish councils first in the their
neighborhood development plan clearly we
currently speak for the interpretation
of that that the neighborhood's
development plan team wrote those
policies so they'll know how best to
interpret those policies so I'm finding
it difficult to argue against them on on
the one hand but there's nothing
specific within their NDP that would
otherwise support this so I thought that
one I think is finally balanced but
interpretation of our own policy I do
believe our case officer has done a very
good job of putting together a report
explaining the the interpretation and
how we we should be interpreting in it
we've seen that within our update sheet
and again through the questions of
clarity so to my mind the report is is
correct as interpreted things the way
should interpret it then comes down I
guess to a balance of harm versus
economic benefit and whilst yes there
will be some economic benefit and yes we
want to be encouraging people to grow
their businesses and to develop
economically strong businesses within
the district we do have to weigh that
against the policy that we have and we
do have a very clear policy to my mind
this has been interpreted correctly and
I do believe we should be refusing in
line with those officers recommendation
in fact I will propose that we do do
that thank you
I think you cancel Richards proposal do
we have a seconder at this point I
notice counts Adam would like to speak
canceled Adam would you like to come in
Thank You chairman I was after going to
agree with counsels Perry and Dixon in
supporting that this be granted I think
reading policy CS 24 I can appreciate
I'll find the balances on this and I
think the interpretation is a reasonable
one to take however given the the
situation that the applicant is clearly
in the support from the local community
and the doubt that was cast upon the
assessment of the development plan of
Paris council I think that in my opinion
it would be not unreasonable to suggest
that this would fall under CS 24
comfortably based on the reading of the
criteria required and I'd like to
propose that we grant it against the
officers recommendation Thank You
Carolyn right speak so we've know about
two propositions and I'll come back more
written down but we'll come back to
those our second counts as more at stake
Thank You chair I'm going to go the
opposite way to cancer out in there and
go with councillor Richards opinion or
thing I very much minded and appreciate
councillor Perry ending stand and Adams
you point on the fact of the world is
changing we do definitely need to
support businesses at the moment but I
keep coming back to the fact that the
policies are there and they have been
there and they should be adhered to
because the world may well go back to
what it was so I'm second counselor
Richards proposal to refuse
thank you very much okay so all right we
do have proposition and a second I I
think unless anybody else wants to speak
should we should we take the vote the
proposition which we've gotta go with
first because it was the first one
proposal it was the first one second it
was to go with officers recommendations
as proposed by a counselor Richardson
second my accounts that Eden to refuse
this application there's anything else
we need to go through before we go to a
vote on this lesson good opinion tummy
all I'm doing comes out of order so
should we go through a thorough vote on
this Olivia would you mind giving us the
roll call please
so the proposition obviously is to
refuse accounts the Kendall against
Houser Richards counselor Richards for
Chancellor Adam Keller Adam against
counselor Dixon
Castle Dixon you're muted councillor
Dixon against councillor Eden yes redden
for cancer Jennings councillor Jennings
against
and counts the pair a counselor Perry
against chair that's five against and do
four thank you so the proposition falls
we have got a second proposition one for
grant before we go to that I think I
should go to offices and just double
check because we do need to make sure
that if we're going to go towards ground
which I think we are we need possible
conditions so do we have a set of
conditions that can be attached to this
please Tracy or Erin would like to run
us through any conditions do you have
some conditions and which we could then
look to get the details to be agreed
with yourself and with members of minded
to support the application and so it'd
be the standard conditions of at the
time limit the approved plans of
highways conditions that have been
recommended by and watched and council
fire and rescue condition network rail
conditions and when it comes to the
caravans would be looking to limit it to
those set out in the description so
touring units only and that the touring
units be removed when they're no longer
required not for residential purposes
for the touring units with only the one
mobile home for residential full-time
purposes and for holiday accommodation
and the number of pitches the number of
caravans and tents which shouldn't
exceed 51 any one point apart from the
mobile home so it'd be the mobile home
and fifty one touring units or all tents
and the death in terms of the details of
the enclosures around the mobile home
the number of months that the site can
operate and then we've got water Bert's
for the building fins for the mobile
home sewage treatment plant details that
the landscaping be retained for five
years as proposed as part of the
development and details of the
facilities unit electric vehicle
charging points hard standing and then a
number of notes as well including the UM
PPF landscaping highways and the
footpath note so those are the sort of
conditions that officers would be
looking to suggested members are minded
to support the application and it really
comes down to making sure that we retain
the development in to what members are
looking to support this evening Thank
You Erin
the conditions you say rough conditions
I think they sound a really detailed but
I think we probably looked though to
come back to discussion finalizing with
myself on trial committee I'll be happy
with that before we move on we do need
chat could I ask Tracey Humphrey it's
just to follow on as well anything to
add that please Thank You chairman yes
just to back up what aaron has said
there obviously there's quite a number
of conditions there some of which would
be quite restrictive it would be our
intention I think to negotiate those and
include the applicant and their agent in
those discussions because clearly they
would have a right of appeal against
some of those conditions and I think we
would want to explore with them before
we bring to you a set of conditions the
extent to which they would be agreeing
to abide by those so if members do vote
to approve the application
we'd like to I think to have that
negotiation with the applicant and then
we can bring back their suggested
conditions through yourself hopefully
and and see what what range of mutually
agreed conditions are possible or indeed
if there's a continued debate we can
bring that situation back to you as well
thank you that would work well need to
explain during the meeting of course
precisely what our reasons are for going
against officers recommendations and
councillor Perry you've indicated that
you'd be happy to second the proposal to
grant this would you be happy to go over
the reasons that you'll have you would
go against the officers recommendation
I'm sure what thank thank you chairman
and well basically on that I would be
very happy to secondly proposals I do
feel under policy cs2 4 which is our
tourism and leisure development section
within the call strategy is is that the
there is evidence there that they talk
about the role of tourism being
increased by supporting the growth and
improvement of existing attractions well
there's you know there are they're
currently using caravans there it is a
tourist attraction just you know camping
a caravan as
as I'm concerned I also think hs2 is
going to get so much interest that
people will want to come and have a look
and see how the developments going but
it also says here large-scale schemes
visitors attractions are overnight you
know
whilst I think that I do think there are
a number of areas of as a same CS 24
which highlights the tourism and leisure
development and camping in caravan is is
is easily sure activity and I think that
needs to be brought in as well it's
we're not just talking about tourism
here camping and caravanning is a
leisure activity and there are sections
I mean without having to go through each
one I mean the officers know it
backwards but there's there's loads of
sections within CS 24 that I feel that
we could use to support it I think for
the purposes of meeting we're very much
along the lines of there's policy
reasons that the benefits of this scheme
vastly vastly outweigh any any drawbacks
so a s-10 chairman yes
s10 yes 24 CS 22 this spirit of what
we're trying to say lives in all of
those yes sir I I'm content that has
been aired properly in the meeting I
take just going to confirm cancer power
you're happy to second the proposition
yeah I'm happy to second Lewis thank you
so council Dixon you asked comment at
this point very quickly I did very
quickly when it comes to evey points can
we have ten percent of the number of the
plots ie if there's fifty one plots
perhaps five e V charging points in
conditions so maybe I'm gonna trace your
arrant to the feedback on your thoughts
regarding electric vehicle points
would that be something we could maybe
add as a note yes we could add it as a
note and it's part of the proposal if
members reminder to have 10% conditioned
as part of this info nice German yeah we
can we can look at that I think as part
of the negotiation there is on detail
conditions we can look at what's
appropriate for conditions and what
would be appropriate as a note and
obviously we can bring that and agree
that through you in due course okay
cassadee's is not in so I presume he's
happy right so I think we move to the
vote on this one so we have in
propositions been thousand seconded that
we grant this application the conditions
of course to be have been outlined
tonight and will be set with myself
we have also taken into account all of
the updates on the update sheets tonight
I think we're ready to go to the vote
Olivia Kendall helps the Kendall for
Chancellor Richards and as the Richards
against that's the Adam Adam for that's
the Dixon councillor Dixon for
councillor Eddin
sorry Kay it's written against cats lair
Jennings caocao Jennings Paul and
councillor Perry councillor Perry fool
yeah that's five for and you against
wonderful thank you very much for that
sir the committee they have four results
do grant application reference 19 / 0 to
9 to 3 / f UL right now we can move to
item 5 our next application is evening
or the hood from Democratic Services we
got the speaker so we ready to move to
the next application if I could just
double check excuse me chairman we
usually agree to have a five-minute
recess to allow speakers to call in okay
in that case everybody five minutes from
there thank you very much adjourned for
five minutes
I could remind animation
are you sure like the mutant love me
you
okay right I'm informed that we've got
all our speakers back in now so I think
we continue the meeting everyone's okay
stuff right lovely
so the meetings now live again wonderful
we continued right of I found on page 19
of your agendas
Liz's application reference 2000 2 3 4 /
o UT which is land to the west of
Western Road strata 11 and is for the
erection of a care home for residents
requiring nursing dementia residential
care with associated parking both the
stores outdoor amenity space and
separate refuse and recycling facilities
the presenting opposite is Alice kosnett
Alice over to you
Thank You chairman so I'm just going to
share my screen
so can you just confirm that you can see
that please perfect yes nothing I'll
just scroll through just a test that's
all working okay
excellent perfect thank you chairman the
application site as identified by the
black dot in the centre of the plan is
located in the town of
stratford-upon-avon the application site
as outlined in red bits the train
station car park to its south train line
to its west a gym and canal to its north
and industrial units to its east the
boundary of the canal water
regeneration zone also lines the north
and boundary of the site this slide
shows the relationship of the site to
the train station train line and
industrial units and car showrooms on
Western Road the recently constructed
development at Arden Quarter is located
to the south east of the site the
application before members this evening
is an outline application for the
erection of a care home with access and
layout for determination under this
application appearance landscaping and
scale would be reserved for later
consideration members should note that
the to site plans on screen are the same
in the right-hand image the plan has
been zoomed in the plan shows that
access and layout proposed access Leibig
aims at the northeast corner of the site
the layout of the site includes the
building's footprint general areas for
outdoor amenity space and landscaping as
well as car and cycle parking
although appearance and scale are
reserved the parameters provided at this
stage are for a care home of up to 95
beds and up to 4 storeys in height
policy CS 26 identifies an area of the
site as a future road link from Western
Road to Birmingham Road and the layout
plan incorporates in this location here
undeveloped land where this link could
be developed where it to come forward in
the future this photograph is taken from
the train station car park to the south
of the application site which is beyond
the white fencing the railway line is to
the left of the photo out of view
this photograph is taken from Western
Road looking toward the site which is
again beyond the white fencing again
from Western Road here we are looking in
a southerly direction with the
application side beyond the fencing the
train station can just be seen in the
distance and roof of Morrison's
supermarkets on the right hand side this
photo is taken around the corner of
Western Road the application site is the
area of grassland in the distance
chairman this application is an outline
with principal access and layout to the
consideration the principle of
development is acceptable as is the
impacts on highway safety and amenity
for future residents subject to a
section 106 agreement to secure
financial contributions and biodiversity
offsetting and conditions as detailed in
the committee report the recommendation
is to grant this planning application
Thank You chairman perfect thank you
right okay okay so our first speaker on
those applications councillor Ian
fragile II from Stratford opponent Town
Council councillor fragile EU that
please
cats the fragile II its star zero star
six oh yeah got you now counsel
translate lovely stuff thank you can
hear you very thank you so as you know
you've got three minutes to speak
please don't end the call at the end of
your three minutes and we may have
questions for you and I'll give you a
warning at thirty Seconds okay thank you
okay over to you sir thank you the town
council agree both the County Council
and the Stratford doctors regarding
Stratford approaching market saturation
in care accommodation particularly where
the Stratford local health and social
care infrastructure he's already under
extreme pressure I understand that there
is no local need especially when the
care home is aligned to the level of
weekly fees charged in berkeley care
home in warwick which implies that the
prospective occupants will be coming
from elsewhere in the country making an
even larger increased pressure on our
local doctors and health care local
feelings were such that the town council
hosted a meeting at the town hall and
present were town is clickin county
councillors the developer doctors and
watch the county calcification after a
lengthy extra views the final suggestion
was the developer would be build an
additional payment to the local health
services to the level of one day service
per week the town council asked this
application to be refused however if the
committee is mindful to grant then it
should should do only to only do so when
the day of the week funding to the local
health service and doctors is part of
the deal thank you
do you have any questions from the
committee please just indicate in the
chat Thank You councillor Richards Thank
You councillor just hear castor Freddie
you talked about the the needs
assessment and whether the fact that the
nice or the current supplies under
strain we've had a Annie's assessment
that indicates that there is an unmet
need have you got any evidence to
support your assertion that it's
currently under strain and therefore
there is no need this information was
coming from Tim Willis at the County
Council okay and from and from the
doctors themselves of course okay okay
how do we have any other questions from
the committee
councillor Perry Thank You chairman and
council of Bradley um I just wondered
whether Town Council that done any
specific research with the care homes in
the town center itself to ascertain what
the actual need is I mean from personal
experience I know there's a desperate
need for dementia care because not all
care homes they say they do provide
dementia care but in real terms they
don't I would just like to know what
what research the Town Council did the
as I said to counsel Richards the
information was coming from the County
Council and the doctors themselves the
doctors are the people under a greater
stress because we we used to have for
doctors surgeries in Stratford and one
often was closed so the three doctors
surgeries that are now left have to
cater for the whole four that was there
okay thank you I think I think Freddie's
given the answer he can get at this
point are there any other questions to
the town council please to give a second
in the chat see if anything is loaded
okay there isn't in that case Council
for actually thank you very much for
your time tonight thank you I can go
back to watching that thank you very
much
Robert thank you we go to our next
speaker then which is the agent of the
applicant Andrew Murphy please mr.
Murphy you there
how's that mr. Murphy's their chairman
but he's still on mute is it star six
did you say
yes 6 mr. Murphy
Oh can you hear me now I've got your
perfect right as before you have three
minutes I'll give you a warning at 30
seconds please don't leave the line
until we've had the opportunity to ask
you any questions thank you sir this is
an empty derelict brownfield parcel of
land in probably the most sustainable
location in the whole district
it is not allocated in any local plan
for any type of use it lies outside the
canal quarter regeneration zone and the
land owner vintage trains has no
intention of building a steam railway
center on the land and previous planning
applications for a steam railway Center
expired a long ago it is not necessary
to demonstrate a need for a care home
because a care home on this side is
acceptable in principle nevertheless a
comprehensive assessment within a six
mile catchment area has demonstrated an
existing need for 165 beds rising to 275
beds by 2031 and an over 65 population
in the in the town well above the
national average and is expected to grow
further in the future further benefits
to the local community involve visual
enhancement of a derelict site
construction jobs up to 100 full-time
staffing jobs increased expenditure in
local shops and services and 100,000
pounds spent on biodiversity enhancement
the Town Council objects because they
are concerned about a harmful impact on
existing medical facilities in the town
however no factual evidence has been
presented to substantiate this claim in
contrast there are several reasons why
the proposed care home will not be a
burden future residents of the care home
are likely to derive from the local area
with pre-existing health conditions and
already registered with the local GP
practice their health needs are not
manufactured or exacerbated by the care
home quite the opposite
nursing and dementia care will be
provided within a specialist unit in the
building on-site support reduces the
number of trips of trips to GPS thereby
reducing GP waiting Lee
the care home can become a support
service for local doctors and medical
services particularly in dealing with
routine health matters a room will be
made available for a visiting
practitioner to hold an in-house surgery
and there are social benefits from
greater community interaction among the
elderly thus reducing loneliness ensuite
shower rooms will make it easier to
place residents Inc in quarantine if
necessary
and finally the NHS South watcher
foundation trust and the NHS Clinical
Commissioning group are of a key council
T's on this matter
each has lodged no objection subject to
financial decisions amounting to 60,000
pounds to mitigate any impact on local
healthcare infrastructure I therefore
commend this 95 bed care home to you as
a highly positive development for the
town that complies with all relevant
planning policies thank you miss Murphy
thank you very much excellently tiled as
well do we have any questions from the
community please cancel Jennings
councillor Jennings I'm sorry it blipped
my computer blipped just as you're
getting on to the subject to 60,000
pounds I'm not sure if I was just as
surprised to hear that but if you could
just refresh me and just go over that
line one more time please
yes so there are two parts the NHS that
the NHS foundation trust in the NHS
Clinical Commissioning group they both
they're both in you know semi
independent and they have separately
lodged no objection subjects two summers
of money it's roughly 20 thousand pounds
for one and about 40 thousand pounds for
the other so in other words fails to put
enough money on on local health
facilities to be spent as they wish that
is their request it's what they want
from the application we are happy to
deliver it through a section 106
payments thanks so thank you very much
right we move then to Adam for a
question please
I think chairman it was just in relation
to the needs assessment that was carried
out now believe the representative
stated 275 beds now looking out what was
in it I see 26 being the unmet need a
current and then it goes on to say a
more realistic realistic measure might
be 165 I don't I don't see whether 275
is coming from right so they've
concluded that there's about a hundred
and sixty five beds in need at the
moment
rising to 275 beds in the future so I'm
just looking at the care at the needs
assessment now it's quite a lengthy
documents but in one paragraph I'm
looking at paragraph 23 point seven of
their report and they say predicted
unmet need for the market standard bed
spaces is by 2031 it's going to be 275
spaces so that after that the research
that they've carried out okay thank you
for that thank you I'm not picking up
any more questions in the chat unless
I'm getting five seconds four three two
well in that case there's no other
questions mr. Murphy thank you very much
for your time so it's greatly
appreciated thank you okay
we should move to our ward member with
understand how what member actually is
declined to speak he registered and
devoted himself so he's not in tonight
so we can move two points of
clarification
does anybody have any points that let's
clarify with the officers
I have one to start with before we go
further
during the parents are the town councils
statement they counselor Fran she
mentioned something about day of the
week funding I will be confused by the
term ovations on that yes of course
chairman so I was actually at the
meeting it was the applicant was there
and as a stakeholder engagement with the
Town Council and and he did offer this
service he could contribute a financial
contribution for a doctor as an extra
day service that is a facility
completely separate to the planning
system essentially so it was a private
offer a dodo whether anything's come off
of it the correct procedure for us is to
consult with the NHS authority
Foundation Trust and the NHS Clinical
Commissioning group and they have simply
requested those financial contributions
which the applicant has agreed to pay so
there wouldn't be any additional
contributions through the section 106
agreement on the planning permission if
forthcoming which would require any sort
of day service thank you Oh given I'd be
involved with application a few years
ago that was which was similar in a way
where the were the applicant and the
company they were representing offered a
number of other additional things that
wouldn't usually fall into one of six
creams and these were secured by an
external additional agreement which was
enforceable by the parent by the council
by the district council given that we
have no knowledge of this day service
having been mentioned we're not in a
position to mention it put that evening
a note are we as part of the conditions
for this no we're not as I say it
wouldn't meet the necessary tests of 106
requirements and similarly there's been
no formal offer in writing it was sort
of mentioned in a meeting and I don't
understand that there's been any further
discussion certainly not involving the
council it respects if that matter so I
wouldn't suggest even putting a note on
any forthcoming permission I just wanted
to
clear that up in my own line before we
want thank you for that not picking up
there are any other points of
clarification so unless anyone chokes up
very quickly I think we go to the debate
so maybe who'd like to start the debate
ah excellent counselor parrot straight
in there cats parrot
sorry chairman and well actually I can't
see any material planning with reason to
refuse this and also whilst I understand
the concerns that may have been raised
by the GP practices we've got no
evidence of that and actually that is
down to the Clinical Commissioning group
to address capacity in GP surgeries so
I'd like to go straight to a proposal to
support the officers recommendation and
grant for this application
chairman you're a mute oh I don't
sorry apologies again I know there are
number of people want to speak on this
and I'm guessing they'll be better
unmuting themselves let's run through
them we go for Peter Richards next
please councillor Richards Thank You
chairman I can't swear speaking I
heartily agree with counsel Parian on
her statements there's no clear evidence
to support the assertions made by the
Town Council that would go against the
needs assessment that we do have in
front of the evidence that we have in
front of us from the needs assessment so
on that basis I'm entirely happy to
second administrator to a vote
Thank You councillor Richards I'm gonna
give them an option to speak so I'll run
as but I'll take it as seconding that so
it's been proper proposed and seconded
councillor Dixon you're next Thank You
chairman I was prepared a second but my
question really is as the eldest member
here by 2031 I'll be in my 80s
should I be declaring an interest I
think that is right thank you very much
and then we go to do councillor Jennings
councillor Richards beat me to it
just like to say I told hardly agree
with him and no I'm a second it's
already been seconded thank you very
much everybody
well there's nobody else indicating and
I think we've got a proposal we've got a
seconder that we threw out this
application would you like to go to the
roll call force loquendo
councillor Kendall for Richards house
the Richards for that's Adam counselor
Adam in for Chancellor Dixon Castle the
Dixon for councillor for perhaps the
Jennings chance or Jennings for and
cannot slip are a councillor Perry for
that's unanimous chair okay thank you
very much in that case the committee
results to grant application reference
20 / 0 0 2 3 4 / o UT will take another
five minute brief adjournment while we
prepare ourselves right and six five
minutes please
you
okay I think we have the speaker that we
need in the meeting so we're ready to go
let's reconvene the meeting please
everybody before we reconvene I just
want to clarify trace Humphries has just
reminded me I just need to clarify the
previous application was of course the
committee resolved to grab that
application to 2000 two three four slash
o UT subject to the water of six legal
agreements as well
okay so I've just confirmed that right
that being said we can now move to item
6 which is found on page 41 of your
agenda this is application reference 20
/ 0 0 5 5 6 / very the site address is
Highland pool headline Tanith Nam in
Arden and is for the removal of
reference to Class E in condition number
5 of Planck mission 19 / 0 3 4 4 4 / ful
to allow owner tourette incidental
outbuildings presenting offset is Tony
Horton Tony over to you Thank You
chairman I will just share the
presentation with members just bear with
me
you
hopefully you can see that I can see
that right thank you
okay so the top slide is the committee
location plan so it shows the sites
which is the black dot in open country
side and part of the West Midlands
Greenbelt and the land is due north of
town within Hardin the sausage read
taken from the committee papers as well
so Highland is a detached house within a
large plot set within ribbon
developments of on poor head Lane move
on to the elevations the property was
originally a small bungalow but since
around about the mid-1970s it's had
incremental extensions to it and
officers are therefore in recent years
resisted voted further volume increases
however a permission was granted for a
first floor extension under application
nineteen slash zero three four four four
ful and that permission required the
demolition of the garage to the side and
the sitting room behind that as part of
the compensation for the increasing
volume so the elevations that you can
see there on the left hand side is the
existing front elevation as the property
currently stands so the right of that
the yellow area is comparative of the
existing front elevation and then above
there is the permitted the the first
floor extension has been granted under
the previous planning permission and
there on the bottom are the elevations
which shows the garage elements with the
sitting room behind having been removed
and the gap to the side I'll move on to
the floor plans first of all the first
floor so on the left-hand side there we
have the existing properties so there
are the three bedrooms and the two
bathrooms and then a void space above
the the garage area and on the right
hand side we have the the permitted
permission
it's got these two additional bedrooms
with ensuite they'll make that a five
bedroom property and it's showing the
elements here which is the garage with
the sitting room behind has been
demolished and then on to the ground
floor plans so the existing on the left
you can see we have the garage with
sitting room behind and then if you
swing over to the right see that the
garage and part of that city room I've
demolished to compensate for the volume
of the first floor extension and in the
process the applicant saw go to
reconfigure the rear of the ground floor
to provide the kitchen dining room and
family room at the back there the area
here will have gated access and be hard
standing and then I've got a photograph
of the front elevation so the garage
elements here is to be taken away first
floor extension on there and there are
planning conditions to require the
demolition of the garage and also
planning condition to remove permitted
development rights which include the
rights to extend the property and also
the rights to have our buildings and
other developments within the curtilage
and it is that elements plus a
outbuildings and development within the
curtilage which the applicants are
seeking to retain and which officers
consider should be still deleted and so
still the primitive rights not given
chairman there's one update letter from
a neighbor which is reported in the
update report and the recommendation is
to refuse the very variation of the
wording of condition five of the extent
Planning Commission thank you thank you
very much Tony before we go to our first
speaker I should just note people
watching that councillor Dixon has
stepped off the committee for this
application as stated at the beginning
of the meeting because of course this is
in his ward and he has will be speaking
as the ward member just to confirm that
for everybody right thank you very much
Tony for an excellent presentation we go
to our first speaker we're on the road
just play as soon as the agent for the
applicant are you there can you hear me
now
Oh perfect lovely first time excellent
story I understand what the first
speakers meant about the time delay
because obviously I can see what
happened and I can't hear you at the
same time I'm trying to speak to you
it's very confusing but anyway we are
where we are so as you've been here
before you know the routine you have
three minutes
please don't end the call at the end of
the three minutes we may have some
questions for you and of course I will
give you a warning at thirty Seconds
this application is solely about
planning conditions and more
particularly about the planet condition
which will prevent a property owner from
being able to erect buildings incidental
to the use of his house and the
permitted development rights the so
called Class E the National Planning
policy framework states that planning
conditions should only be attached to a
permission if they meet six Tests they
must be necessary relevant to planning
relevant to the development to be
permitted enforceable precise and
reasonable in all other respects
national guidance online notes that
conditions which restrict the future use
of permitted development rights may not
pass the tests of reasonableness or
necessity Highlands as you have heard is
a detached property with a large garden
the property currently benefits from all
its permitted development rights and as
such could erect buildings incidental to
the enjoyment of a house under Class E
without recourse to the council things
like green houses summer houses and
sheds the offices report regarding the
approved scheme noted that Highlands
started out as a modest bungalow and
that as a result of the size increase
over the years and given its Greenbelt
setting it is considered appropriate to
remove permitted development rights to
prevent any further enlargement I don't
disagree with this the house has already
been extended considerably and further
extensions would be contrary to your
development plan but your officer made
no reference to the erection of
incidental outbuildings in the
determination of the application because
such a consideration had no bearing on
whether the proposed alterations to the
dwelling were accepted
or policy compliant yet the right to
erect such buildings under classy were
removed without justifications the
removal is unnecessary and unreasonable
and the condition therefore fails to
international tests the council now says
that the removal of the permitted
development right is to prevent the
erection of a garret adjacent to the
house but it does so much more it
removes the rights to erect any
outbuilding no matter how small and that
is what is so unreasonable if the
government intended to prevent the
erection of incidental outbuildings for
houses in the Greenbelt there would be a
blanket removal but there is not so when
determining this application I ask you
to consider whether the removal of the
rights to erect the incidental
outbuilding is reasonable or necessary
to ensure the proposal for the house
extension complies with the development
plan I would suggest that it is not and
therefore that the application should be
approved and just a final thought if the
application is approved it is likely
that the owner will erect a garage to
the side of the altered house under his
permitted development rights however
however if the application is refused
the owners will still be able to erect
the garage until the extensions
permission is implemented the garret
would have to be set behind the existing
house but when the house works are
complete it would be visible from the
street and would be far more intrusive
to the adjacent neighbors at Meadow View
so do the committee have any questions
please for the applicants agent just
pause for a second okay I'm getting no
questions here so in which case Roy
Rogers thank you very much for your time
tonight and greatly appreciated thank
you okay
we'll move to our next speaker who's our
board member councillor Dixon
that's the Dixon you have five minutes
before I start can I just check with
Tony that he has
photographs ready for a run through
essentially Tony after my first opening
paragraphs I should run through them as
a single sequence but the prompt is the
word next and I would ask that you move
on at that time
once the photographs start appearing
please don't come back to me as the as
the image Thank You chairman I'll so now
start
thank you this assessment is to be made
the assessment to be made when
considering extensions to properties in
the green belt is does it harm the
openness of the green belt officers
often use volume calculations to aid
their assessments but decisions are not
numbered driven for example a decision
last week included this phrase when
taking into account the visual impact of
the dwellings presence the cumulative
impact of this proposal is unlikely to
detrimental impact upon the openness of
the green belt to a harmful extent the
increase over the original building is
calculated at 92 percent and increase
from the current seventy-seven percent
and only DP writes a and B were
withdrawn that is an application around
the corner from Highland I now ask Tony
to show the series of photographs thank
you Tony for putting that first one up
the first one the current property you
can probably assess where the original
bungalow was prior to the first floor
gable fronted extension which was
granted permission in 1992 next please
don't it a picture of the of a refused
application two years ago the volume
calculation was 111 percent against the
current 55 percent increase from the
1992 conversion next please Tony this is
the application withdrawn last year when
the planners were about to recommend
refusal again because the volume was
still 88% you can see the dotted line
depicting the
current outline of the property there
was no increase in the footprint just
the extra volume of the roof I would
have supported this application had it
come to committee and interestingly the
parish council did not object next
please Tony the area where a tandem
garage will be built if tonight's
application is refused and PD rights are
not reinstated next please
the next are two pictures of typical
outbuildings which in future would need
planning consent to be replicated and
could therefore be judged as
inappropriate if you do not support this
application to reinstate PD rights the
next please that's another typical
shared outbuilding and the next please
Tony a new house built across the road
from where the garage has been relocated
and an infill site created please
remember this picture next please
this shows where that garage was
relocated to the other side into the
front garden on the other side of the
large plot next please Tony now another
example this one is two plots away from
Highland again you can see an extensive
extension to the side next please Tony
this is a new application granted only
last week policy it hasn't changed very
much
this shows the property as it is now and
the next and last picture shows the
approved extension but this house is not
in the local service village which
Highlands is but in the open countryside
all these examples have been assessed to
have acceptable impact upon the openness
of the Greenbelt the officers feel that
the double garage at the side of Island
would however be detrimental and harm
the openness of the Greenbelt I am of
the opposite persuasion tonight you have
heard what will happen if you support
the officers recommendation
do not reinstate PD rights a new double
lane tandem garage behind the existing
garage destroying greenery and laying
more down down more hard surface I have
shown local examples where the impact on
the openness was considered acceptable
and I have pointed out that it is not a
matter of calculation of volume but of
impact you now need to decide which is
the fairest most practical and the least
damaging option a double gouge to the
side which is supported by the neighbors
or a tandem garage at the rear laying
down more tarmac 30 seconds the new SPD
on climate change is coming to the
council next week by the way
the couple who built the new house where
the garage was relocated to the front
garden on the other side are the same
couple who converted Highland from the
bungalow in 1992 into the house you see
today some people are lucky others just
come up against guidelines you have the
opportunity tonight to grant fairness
and the practical solution I ask you to
vote in favor of the application right
do we have any questions for the ward
member please thank you very much thank
you right points of clarification for
the officers do you have any quotes of
clarification moment Thank You counsel
thank you
Tony it it was just in relation to the
way in which the the the full
application was conditioned
now obviously the permitted development
rights is a mechanism to achieve what
offices or as a suitable way to restrict
overdevelopment are there are other
mechanisms that might be able to do that
without restricting these rights that
the clearly contentious enough to have
this variation application come in I
can't think of any other way that
officers could control development other
than by legal agreements which seems
heavy-handed in this case the removal of
development rights is to ensure that the
openness of the Greenbelt is maintained
and to prevent the urban sprawl and that
would be done by requiring further
planning permission for extensions and
outbuildings that's not to say the local
planning authority wouldn't necessarily
grunt those but it would need to have
the control over that so it could assess
the the case and the impact on the
Greenbelt yeah I think mechanisms would
be even what's being suggested tonight
for a new planning application to
reflect what what's effectively being
else which is to retain the carriage and
am i right in understanding that yes the
the applicants could make another
application to with the scheme which
included the garage and retained it in
that form they could also apply to vary
the condition on the original permission
which requires the demolition of the
garage so I think they could apply to
have that condition removed or they
could appeal against the conditions or
appeal against any decision if we refuse
the application tonight thank you thank
you before we move to a debate
no in that case the debate ought to
start kickin suck on this Sir Richard's
perfect timing
Thank You councillor Kendall against the
Richard speaking and so I'm a bit
concerned that the presentations that
we've had appears to be reopening or
seeking to reopen the debate over the
original application we're not looking
to decide on the location or design or
size of a garage we're being asked to
look at a condition has been put on it
has been made abundantly clear within
the officers report and by our officer
that without the removal of the existing
carried sorry without removing the
missing development rights of class II
then the application the previous
application wouldn't have been granted
and I don't think it's right that we
should be threatened with the potential
for a garage being located elsewhere
we're not here to determine that that if
if the applicant were minded to build
such a garage then that would have to be
compliant with planning law and it is
down to our officers and to our
enforcement team to determine if it is
lawful for them to do that
they will do that in time we need to
decide on whether it is appropriate and
right that this condition was put on and
as I say it's been made very clear
within the officers report and again
verbally by the officer that it is so
with that I will propose that we go with
the offerors officers recommendation and
refuse the applicant application
Katherine there's really no reason for
us to go against officer recommendation
I'm happy second it but let's go through
the speaker's who wish to come in cats
Adam first place
and I think Joan um yeah I was going to
reiterate that I think the the question
that I asked for clarification
essentially and that there isn't a
mechanism to ensure that there is no
removing the plate further development
of the site couldn't be achieved through
further permissions I think it's
difficult given that the neighboring
properties and the development in that
area otherwise but I think
chance Raja me frozen in terms of how we
operate as as a planning on
for setting a pattern for the control
mechanisms there
you can't Estrada okay we don't we can
catch the hairy Nair oh sorry we're
struggling with your own connection have
you finished
have you finished your points I'm sorry
yeah no it's fine I'll leave it there
just I think the points I was going to
make her have been made anyway Thank You
Kayla will new counselor Perry Thank You
chairman excellently put councillor
Richards and I would actually you know
at the end of the day conditions are set
on planning the granting of planning
permissions that the conditions are set
there for a very good reason and at the
end of the day if the applicant wants to
put a garage somewhere or a summer house
they just go through the process of
planning permission we're not here
saying tonight that they can't have them
where they want them but we're talking
about a process and a precedent here and
so I will be going with the officers
recommendation okay right well
syndication they want to speak
councillor Richards proposed that we
follow the officers recommendation to
refuse I'm happy to second but I think
you have to do is go to a roll call for
the vote
if everyone does not deal with that
Olivia we start councillor Kendall for
Richards councillor Richards for
Chancellor Adam
counselor hadn't for that's the Edden
it's reading for counselor Jennings
counselor Jenny's ball and cancer / a
counselor Perry fall that's unanimous Jo
thank you there for the committee
resolves to refuse application reference
20 / 0 0 5 5 6 / Larry that's our last
item analyze the application for the
evening
Olivia do we have any urgent business I
don't think we do well in that case I
think that brings us to the end of this
evenings meeting thank you very much to
officers members of the committee
applicants all speakers it's been a
pleasure thank you very much we can
close the meeting
you